hi I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Jerry welcome
two reasons to see where we give you
reasons to see and not to see the coal
so let's hang out when veteran 9-1-1
operator jordan turner receives a phone
call that a little girl has just been
abducted she soon realizes that she has
to confront a killer from her past in
order to save the girl's life
Ryan's Consensus I think there are a lot
of reasons to see the call there are a
lot of reasons to see the call yeah this
movies just a fun Hollywood thrill ride
Jerry's Consensus yeah I think there are
a lot of reasons to see the Ko'olau
surprise there are a lot of reasons to
see the call I wasn't expecting a whole
lot out of that trailer cuz it kind of
spells out a lot of the movie free but I
actually had a really good time I dug I
really dug about 90% of this movie
reason to see number one Halle Berry she
plays the 911 operator and you know what
she does a really good job in the
beginning of this movie you see her make
a mistake and then a girl is killed and
in this film you really want her to get
her Redemption yeah and she does a great
job at it she sells the performance you
believe her you believe all our emotions
and I was rooting for her the whole time
oh I was too and things like like you
know the trailer makes it look cheesy
and it makes the performances all look
over the top when you see the movie like
she is committed yeah and and she
doesn't really good job you feel for her
the whole time like you want her you're
right there in her shoes so she hats off
to Halle Berry storm star you did it you
did it reason to see number two
abigail breslin Nessa Abigail Breslin
she plays the girl that's been abducted
from the Burbank mall from the Burbank
mall yeah it's very evident that it's
the Burbank mall and at first I thought
she was kind of annoying she seemed like
a typical teenager but you know what you
really feel for her too you want her to
get out of this situation really bad and
she sells the performance she's very
emotional throughout and I
for her yeah totally I mean I stopped
myself partway through the movie and I
thought just like this must have been a
really traumatizing role different let
it out he's in like a trunk for 40
minutes yeah and she's freaking out and
like twists and turns happened they're
just really tense and and kind of
disturbing at points and it's she
doesn't kill her job in this movie she
does a better job in this movie then the
trailer advertises it to be everybody
does everybody know he is better than
the trailer but have you believed reason
to seat number three Michael Eklund I
don't want to talk too much about
Michael Eklund he plays the serial
killer in this film and because you get
to see him a lot throughout this movie
the trailer isn't shown too much so
since the trailer gives away a lot
already I don't want to say too much
about him but he does a good job you
know he doesn't just play he is quite
creepy serial killer but he doesn't play
it just one note you could feel the
layers to him as he gets to know the
character a little bit more oh yeah I
mean he was one of the big sub big Ursa
prizes to me in this movie cuz you don't
seem like you say you don't see much of
him in the trailer and he looks more
maniacal on the trailer and he in the
movie he brings a lot of dimensions yeah
there's definitely depth in his
performance cuz like at times you you
almost feel he's fascinating it's like
you almost feel sorry and then at times
he's like freaky and and just he gets
under your skin and bottom line he's the
villain and you want this guy to lose
you want him to lose and at the same
time you you sort of get him yes so
without sacrificing his like
intimidating qualities like it's not
like you understand the mean is not
scary anymore he's still free yeah
please gonna see number four thrill ride
that's probably the best way to describe
this movie this movie to me is like a
classic Hollywood thrill ride it does
sort of have a and almost like a really
good b-movie nough sub yet like because
it's a high concept plot yeah and it
delivers on the thrills you know what
are you looking for in this type of
movie you're looking for suspense and
you know what it's not just suspenseful
and thrilling it's also a lot of fun as
well there's like some scary stuff it oh
yeah definitely and like you can tell
because a
and who did this movie like just the way
they shot it like really puts you into
the throttle of everything yeah and just
the everything comes together to make it
a really interesting fun Robin
and the other thing too is like the this
movie has an escalating plot yeah and
it's believable it's surprisingly it's
not a bunch of stuff that's going on you
know I was with a crowd that was so into
this movie and it's been a while since
I've been to a movie where the crowd was
really like whenever it seemed like oh
the the girl might get out of the
situation the crowd was applauding and
stuff that was happening twenty minutes
into the movie yeah I mean that was and
that was the surprising thing is again
that the trailer makes everything look
cheesy and so much of this movie works
because it's surprisingly plausible like
it feels like it could really happen
like they credited like 9/11 one call
center consultant I was like they
probably talked that person for a long
time and it's also an interesting world
to to actually explore you know they
they call it the hive where all the
9-1-1 operators work and it's really
interesting to explore the other end you
know you always explore the cops but you
never get to explore the people on the
line that take the calls yeah and you
get to see how intense their job
actually is even though the trailer
gives a lot of weight it it's it doesn't
ruin the movie at the same time yeah
that's good it's weird out my trailer
can have so many spoilers and pretty
much lay it out beat by beat how this
movie's gonna go yet it's still it's
still suspenseful you still can keep you
on your toes you'll have a great time
reason to see number five
cinematography what I liked about this
film a lot with its cinematography was
uh they switched it was it was really
shot close up you know a lot of the time
and it's cool this sort of specially on
the big screen to see something like
that it makes it a lot more eerie
because they're really exploring their
emotions when you're that close up and
it makes it that much more suspenseful
the cinematography behind it you know
that cool look and everything no yeah it
looks great and the thing is that they
switch the style up depending on where
you are and what's going yes yeah and
you want to be smooth and you want to be
handheld and you want to be super
[ __ ] close-up in the actors faces
because it really does capture the
claustrophobia feel and the intensity of
everything that's going on without the
cinema
hagh Rafi working so well and you know
kusa director Brad Anderson as well for
you know working so well with the
cinematographer on this film the
cinematographic choices you know really
do a good job of putting you in every
moment yeah one one tone I wasn't
expecting out of this film was
creepiness yeah and they really knew how
to provide creepiness when them when it
was necessary alright so we'll move on
to the reasons not to see right now
reasons not to see the third act if you
haven't seen the trailer if you've been
fortunate enough not to see the trailer
don't watch the trailer yeah because
they tell you pretty much what's gonna
happen in the third act but that is
where this film's problems lie but I
will say there's a good two thirds of
this movie that is solid yeah and we're
not gonna ruin what happens in the
finale but it takes some turns one turn
especially the final scene is unexpected
the final scene doesn't really work for
this film but at the same time I was so
you know engrossed by the movie already
but I didn't mind it too much but I did
see how it was very problematic yeah it
was you know it got to a certain point
like though like the last 20 minutes I
was like really with it and then they
make a choice with the plot and it was
the first time during the whole movie I
actually snapped out of it and went you
know what yeah really out of place yeah
and then and it belongs it in different
movies so they kind of they kind of veer
off in a direction and then there is
there's more good stuff it's not like
the whole third act is bad by any
average because there's there's still
some really effective really cool stuff
in the third act but it that's where it
stops being plausible and the and the
problem is that after it's been so
plausible unbelievable all this time and
so well put together then it goes into
some unbelievable places that don't fit
right and then it gets a little
distracting and then yeah like I have
want to applaud them for going try
something different yeah yeah it's like
you had a really unexpected direction
for the end of this movie but on the
other hand none of these characters
would have yeah it didn't fit what the
characters would have done and that was
the biggest problem with the ending it's
like it's it kind of gives
something that a lot of people would
want to do but but you wouldn't do the
reason why we wanted to bring it up is
because a lot of critics are pointing
out that they're not recommending it and
it's mainly based off the third act but
keep in mind the third act got all of it
is bad the crowd was still really into
it at times and there's still two thirds
before that are solid yeah it's it's not
enough to fully ruin the experience yeah
I mean it it does sort of tamper with
with it but there's there's too much
good in this movie to not you know check
it out just because of that you know all
right guys so we'll do a quick recap for
you of the reasons to see and the
reasons not to see the call some reason
to see number one Halle Berry reason to
see number two
Abigail Breslin reason to see number
three Michael Eklund reason to see
number four a thrill ride and reason to
see number five the cinematography and
the reasons not to see the call just one
today the third act and guys thanks for
watching if you want to go ahead and
tell us your reasons to see or not to
see in the comic box below go ahead and
tell us I have a sore throat today in
case you can't tell and if you want to
check out my straight to-the-point
review of the call go ahead and click on
the link right here and if you'd like to
see more episodes of reasons to see
click the link right here and if you
want to get updated every time a new
video is out or a new review is out
subscribe subscribe in this box the box
the box that was a different yeah but
the call is better than the box yeah I
think that's what I've heard that's what
I've heard - I haven't actually seen
I've actually seen the blog Robert the
Box is pretty horrible did anyone watch
the box it tell us live chat box comment
below let us know how it was and compare
it to the call
you